I come from a very small place and well,
being in a big city where
Mexican products are really difficult to
acquire and well, I would like to bring
those types of products that are
proudly Mexican at an affordable price.
I would tell them to cheer up
and break that  scheme that the
woman does not leave the house because for
really this the opportunities are
outside and we can achieve it but the
question is to have strength to be able to
cheer up that they are not afraid what
caught my attention is that first it
is for women directed 100%  for
women and secondly to be able to do
something that we had in mind
and to be able to land it on something and more than
anything to be able to see that there are people who have
the support and the time they have
to be able to give us
that push perhaps because many of
situations sometimes nothing else stays
in mind and we cannot land any
of the projects that possibly
along the way have been having today
I t  I want to do something different and
not just come to employ myself but
because I can't achieve something
great where you can provide
jobs to other people who also
do your own community I feel
very excited I feel very
privileged to be able to be in  this
group of these girls that
we are all in with a goal and to hear
the support that we have from each of the
people that are in this room
with the experience that they have and not
really something that you can have
access to all the  time, let's not be
afraid to go out and look for
opportunities because at some point they
present themselves and it is the moment to take them and
at that moment we have to take advantage of
everything that comes because since he did not comment, they told
us about the opportune
opportunities that always present themselves but it
is a question  of one of wanting to take them and
of the ine not only for example staying
with the academic but will really
carry out the dream and try to complete
everything  what we have in mind
mainly to the consulate I thank you in
advance for having these types of
programs that help us to be able to
carry out
and to be able to count on people of their
quality and who can
enrich us in many areas, both
personally and professionally, sometimes one
He says it's that I can't for the children but
rather for the children I want to
do it for the children it's my
motivation I feel very excited and
lucky this
but he can't believe that these
personalities are here with us and
are with all their intentions to help
us  everyone to grow, it is never too late to
carry out a dream and so
that they look within for that strength
that you need to encourage you to excel
and to encourage you to grow more every day